the premise of the movie is set in the
late king dynasty in china one day a
spoiled young man named wang is taking a
stroll in the market alongside his
minions they come across a beggar named
sukhan laying on the ground wang makes
his people assault the beggar for no
reason humiliating him and calling him
different names they bully the poor guy
but he doesn't bother to retaliate at
last wang pees on him asking him to
quench his thirst after they leave
sukhan is left behind in the street
senseless and beaten he has been living
in misery for the past month but life
was different for him before that the
scene cuts to a few months ago on the
same street wang and his minions steal a
little girl's toy for fun but this time
they are stopped by sukan he is a formal
martial arts expert who is turned into a
beggar even though sukhan's lifestyle is
looked down upon he has gained
popularity because of the fighting
skills that he frequently showcases
because of this he has also gained the
title of the leader of beggars sukan
asks wang for money then proceeds to
beat up his minions eventually justice
is served and the little girl gets her
toy back everyone cheers for sukan
making him the center of attraction that
night something strange happens in the
emperor's residence a guard loses
control of himself and starts attacking
the higher officials his eyes turn milky
white and his nails elongate almost as
if an entity has possessed him the
soldiers try their best to stop him but
the man can hardly be touched the city's
councilman fuka yuhang watches the
incident while hiding and praying for
his life simultaneously the emperor
unaware of everything is sleeping in his
chamber he also has a nightmare of
someone with long nails beheading his
soldiers the emperor wakes up covered in
sweat from the dream and immediately
calls fuca to his chamber by now the
guard has returned to his normal form
and has no memory of what he did the
emperor is informed that the same thing
happened to many people in the city
rumors blame it on a highly contagious
virus but the emperor knows better to
solve the problem he has to worship
heaven for days without meeting anyone
from outside hence he asks fuka to start
an investigation and find the root of
the problem while he is away fuca is
confused about where he should start the
investigation hence he asks his nephew
su can for help sukhan's wife fei-fei is
the woman of the house her orders are
absolute that no one can go against so
when she asks her husband to help fuca
sukan has to agree at the same time we
see a councilman frantically praying in
his house he has been getting nightmares
recently and has an eerie feeling in his
heart suddenly an invisible force knocks
over his bookshelf the man has locked
every door and window in the house with
chains and locks still he is paranoid
that someone has gotten inside his fear
comes to life when he hears someone
whispering behind him is a grim
reaper-like man waiting to end his life
suddenly the councilman is transported
to a dream world where all his
colleagues are killed and mounted on
poles he tries running away but his
limbs are caught and trapped in the end
they are torn apart and the man is
killed in a brutal murder the next day
sukan brings fuka to a brothel with an
excuse to investigate in reality he is
fed up with his wife and wants to have
fun with someone else for the night he
lines up a bunch of beautiful women and
is making his pick when he hears feife
calling him sukan caught in 4k quickly
makes an exit and pretends to be
entering the brothel for the first time
fei-fei knows that it is only an excuse
hence when they get back home she brings
out a whip looking to teach him a lesson
in bed the following morning sukan is
informed about another person being
possessed and killing guards he
immediately comes to their rescue and
once again impresses the people with his
fighting skills however in the middle of
the fight the rival gets an upper hand
and is about to land a fatal attack
right then enters shah ju the descendant
of feng jing religion he defeats the
rival with a single punch gaining
everyone's compliments he addresses
sukan as master and treats him with
respect but still sue can cannot help
but feel a hint of jealousy because of
shaju's popularity later that day sukan
is in the market when half of the crowd
stops abruptly they force an attack on
the other half revealing that they have
been possessed amidst the chaos sukhan
notices the grim reaper on top of a roof
he follows the man and ends up in a
field where he is attacked after a brief
struggle the reaper disappears on his
own back in the market feife is also
fighting the possessed but is about to
be killed then shaju arrives and defeats
every single possessed person he is
praised for saving many lives but the
family of the possessed are in distress
to help them shaju brings their
unconscious bodies to his home and
performs a ritual by the end of the
ritual they return to life and are all
better he also reveals that he has been
trained in white magic and knows a way
to stop the grim reaper sukan on the
other hand is furious that shaju is
getting all the attention to discredit
him he knocks his uncle out and blames
it on shaji's magic but it doesn't take
long before the trick is revealed and he
is humiliated in front of everyone at
midnight shaju comes to sukhan's house
to talk to him about something important
according to him the grim reaper is a
junior who used to learn magic with him
a long time ago he was the best student
the school ever had but was tricked into
failing the final test everyone in the
village apprehended him for cheating
which is why he has returned and is
seeking revenge on everyone fuca is
delighted that they finally have a lead
in the case however they will have to
make a plan to catch the culprit later
sukhan sees fei fei dying after falling
into the river when he goes to help her
he also drowns and ends up in a
hallucination he wakes up in the morning
and realizes he was just dreaming
however the dream was so vivid that he
suspects someone cast a spell on him
later that day wang is troubling people
as usual this time he takes it too far
and has to be stopped by shaju he
teaches the bullies a lesson and gains
appreciation from bystanders yet again
when it gets dark people gather in front
of a shrine to pray fuca pretends to be
sukan to lure the reaper in although he
is not so good at acting the plan works
and the reaper falls right into their
trap he tries to fight sukhan and kill
him but is in turn killed by shaju the
chaos subsides and the killings finally
end in the following scene everyone is
in front of the emperor telling him
about the progress impressed by shaji's
abilities he fails to recognize sukhan's
role in the mission sukan feels
humiliated when his presence isn't
acknowledged while shaji is asked to
stay longer in the palace once he is
alone with the emperor he is asked to
check his health using his magic shaju
predicts the nightmares are a symptom of
heart disease he assures the emperor
that he has a magical medicine that will
make him better in no time in only a few
weeks xiajiu and the emperor become
inseparable shaji's position in the
council rises and he becomes the general
of the palace his disciples also gain
extra respect in society people offer
them free food and services because of
their master then one night fuca calls
sukan outside for an important task but
as they talk he addresses sukhan as
master sue it turns out the person in
front of him is xiajiu wearing fuka's
face he discloses that he is the actual
grim reaper who has been controlling
everyone in the town with his magic for
the past few months
even though he is from a respected
family he was humiliated by the
villagers 10 years ago and has been
longing to take revenge ever since now
that he is just steps away from being
the emperor he has to kill sukan first
and seal the deal before sukhan can
comprehend anything shaju casts a spell
on him they are taken to an imaginary
world where xiaji is a giant he attacks
sukhan but the beggar takes advantage of
his size and narrowly makes an escape to
cast out of the spell sukan uses a
unique dragon technique and lands an
attack they return to the real world but
the battle continues sukhan is
physically stronger but in front of
shaji's spells he is left weakened
xiajjiu wants him to suffer so instead
of killing him he breaks his ankles and
curses him to live like an actual beggar
for the rest of his life at the same
time a troop sent by shaju attacks the
beggar base and kills everyone feife
fights for her life but eventually
suffers the same fate as the others in
the morning sue can returns and finds
out that everyone he ever loved has died
he holds feife and breaks into tears the
only person on his side is fuka who is
thankfully away when the place was
attacked enraged by the sight he goes to
the palace to ask for justice but even
the guards are on xiajiu's side and he
is no longer allowed inside cut to a
month after the incident shaji's curse
has fulfilled itself and sukan has
turned into a miserable beggar the
people who once used to look up to him
now refuse to come near him wang uses
the situation to teach sukhan a lesson
he and his minions take turns peeing on
the poor man still sukan doesn't fight
back and is numb to their insults when
he is at his lowest fuca finds him and
brings him back to his home he has also
lost his job and is in bad financial
condition he eats leftovers from
restaurants and brings the same for his
nephew eventually shaji's disciples
start showing their true faces they
demand free goods and assault everyone
who refuses to obey them people who were
on shajiyu's side before start dreading
his rule that night sukan drinks several
bottles of alcohol and decides to commit
the unthinkable he is about to jump off
a bridge when a stranger saves him it is
none other than his consciousness who
wants him to return to his normal self
and avenge his wife's death in the
morning sukan wakes up with renewed
motivation and a will to take revenge
meanwhile shajiyu's people go on a
rampage and to destroy businesses for
not offering them money a little girl
goes against them but they do not
hesitate to threaten her as well just
when she is about to get hurt sukan
arrives and beats everyone turning into
the town's hero again in the meantime
the emperor has gotten a hint of what
shaji is planning he also finds out the
medicine he is being fed is what causes
him intense nightmares however he is too
weak to fight against chajiu who has all
the palace guards on his side suddenly
sukhan arrives in the palace having
tricked all the guards and the security
system shaju asks everyone to stay away
wanting to defeat sukhan on his own an
intense battle follows where sukan
surprisingly overpowers shaju all the
pain and frustration he has gone through
in the past month comes flowing out of
him he gets a hold of shaji's throat and
is about to kill him but the magician
uses another spell to turn into fife
this sets sukan back a little but he
quickly recovers remembers all the times
that she whipped him and surprises him
with a counter-attack at last shaju is
thrown into the fire and killed shaji's
followers are agitated at their master's
death but before they can attack
sukhan's supporters arrive and fight
them in the last scene sukan is in the
streets continuing his life as a normal
beggar then one day he sees a girl who
looks exactly like fey fay the movie
ends as she offers him a piece of bread
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching